Thank You spider-man
I'm so good hey sorry I'm late
happy look nice thank you you too thank
you
new dress yes it is hot you know what
just happened
[Music]
let's get your passport Peter Parker
here to pick up a passport please
mini toothpaste let's pack your suit I
just want to go on my trip with my
friends Europe doesn't really need a
friendly neighborhood spy
[Music]
you look really pretty therefore I have
value no that's not a nice thing you
look pretty too I spent some time with
MJ I think she likes you to be my first
all love I have just finished my coffee
so nice to finally meet you spider-man
your Nick Fury what some clothes on
let's go for a ride
is he gonna be okay like that might want
to turn him over so he doesn't swallow
his tongue
Nick Fury just hijacked our summer
vacation
get gifts Parker but he had a job to do
are you going to step up or not
all alone your friends are in trouble
what are you gonna do about it
you don't want any part of this
who is that guy he's like Iron Man and
Thor rolled into one he's no spider-man
what is it with you and spider-man what
he looks out for the neighbor it has a
dope suit and I really respect him
sup dickwad
you